welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Attack on Titan the final episode our
protagonist Aaron joerger has now become
the final villain to protect his home
the island of Parade from the outside
world he's unleashed the million
colossal Titans that made up the walls
to kill every other person on the planet
but now all of our main characters from
parody and Marley have banded together
to stop him the last part Ended as
Aaron's friends leapt from the plane for
a final fight on Aaron's giant new
skeletal body plan A is to take out Zeke
the Beast Titan so Rina the Armored
Titan transforms and knocks him
immediately the hope is without Zeke's
Royal Blood Aaron will lose his control
over the eldian founder Amir
unfortunately this wasn't the real Zeke
it was just a construct his real bodies
hidden from him so it's on to plan B
where Armen will use the explosive power
of the Colossal Titan to Nuke this whole
thing but Aaron planned for this so wow
armen's immediately swallowed and taken
off the board so it's on to plan C where
Peak the cart Titan will strap some
Dynamite to Aaron's head and blow it up
the oldfashioned way but oh she's
impaled by another Titan construct
Aaron's made yeah he's got a whole Army
of them every Titan Warrior that's ever
lived including their old friends like
baral but now for Plan D there is no
plan D they're just desperately fighting
to survive and very quickly things look
Bleak but now who's this flying in our
gangs picked up by a giant bird Titan
yeah remember little Falco just got the
power of the jaw Titan and for some
reason his manifested as a bird with the
bird's eye view mikas spots the weird
cow Titan that swallowed Armen so it
sling shot time as she's trying to get
him and it's fight round two where all
our characters get their own hero moment
but they're still just two outnumbered
until one of the construct Titans turns
on the others wait is that our old
friend Amir while arman's unconscious
his mind is in the eldian coordinate
where he hangs out with Zeke who's
basically given up on life but Armen
convinces him humanity is worth saving
without humans you wouldn't have
baseball and the spirits of our other
Titan Warrior friends are here too so
it's like I know you guys are dead but
we could really use your help so all our
dead Titan friends wake up and switch
sides and now m is able to rescue Armen
and Zeke wakes up to Here I Am come kill
me and Captain Levi who's killed the
Beast Titan a dozen times finally puts
him to rest for good and it works the
rumbling stops but Aaron himself is
still a problem so it's Jan who swings
in there grabs the Detonator blows
Aaron's head clean off which reveals the
weird jellyfish vertebrae thing that is
the founding Titan so now it's time for
Aaron's best friend Armen cyanara Aaron
Kaboom nukes the whole thing but of
course it's not going to be that easy
Aaron reforms in a more normal Titan
body the jellyfish thing survived the
blast 2o and now it farts out a bunch of
Titan creating gas transforming all the
eldians into Titans leading the attack
to reconnect with Aaron so it's the
final battle Titan Punch Yeah but Mikasa
is sitting this fight out she can't
bring herself to kill Aaron in fact she
envisions the life they could have had
if he didn't become a genocidal Maniac
but he did so Mikasa accepts what she
has to do swings on in there into this
new Titan's mouth to find Aaron's Prime
body and cuts his head off Mikasa kills
Aaron she gently takes his severed head
and gives it a smooch yes of course
she's always loved him but before Aaron
died with the power of the eldian
coordinate he's able to have a final
chat with his friends to explain his
motivations and turns out he wanted his
friends to kill him his real plan was to
become an apocalyptic threat so parody
and Marley could unite against a common
enemy and with the island eldians saving
the world from him the rest of the world
would accept them and they could finally
have peace so Aaron jger really was good
all along well his motivations at least
he did in fact kill 80% of the world's
population armen's like man I'm sure
there was a better way but our best bros
talk it out realize both their hands are
stained with blood so it's like I love
you man see you in hell so back in
reality Armen and Mikasa mourn their
best friend Aaron now that they
understand his real intentions and with
Aaron's death the jellyfish monster
disappeared it has something to do with
the founder Amir getting over her
abusive relationship of the Old eldian
King Fritz which means the power of the
Titans is gone from the world all our
eldians transform back and the original
Dream of the scouts a world without
Titans is finally realized now they've
just got humans to contend with and
Marley might want to seek retribution
but Aaron's plan seems to work as Armen
says yo we just saved your butts I think
that proves we're not your enemies so
Aaron Jagger caused a near apocalyptic
event but Humanity will eventually
rebuild and the future looks bright a
few years later our crew returns to
parade Island which still under control
of the joists has become even more
militaristic but armen's optimistic that
peace talks will work Mikasa is not with
them she went home earlier to bury
Aaron's head under their favorite tree
she bids farewell to Aaron the man she
loved but had to kill and that's where
Attack on Titan comes to an end except
for the credit scene which shows the
world did go through an era of peace and
prosperity but eventually it seems
humans found another reason to kill each
other and after seemingly destroying
civilization again a young child finds
Aaron's tree which has grown enormous in
fact it looks similar to when Amir found
the jellyfish founding Titan originally
so maybe Titans will come back in the
world who knows if you like this recap
hit that subscribe button for more of
the best Recaps of TV and
movies